stephanie is with us in miami
hi stephanie how are you hi dave i'm
good how are you
better than i deserve what's up um
so my question dave is uh so my husband
lost his job
due to cobia 19. we decided to
defer our mortgage payment even though
i'm still working and i
i'm pretty sure i could afford to make
the payments it would be a little tight
for me
um obviously without that extra income
coming in
my question to you would be should i
continue to make those payments uh what
do you think about that
i mean the way that i look at it it's
not like the payments are on hold
so maybe if you could explain a little
to me what
what i should do well i don't know the
terms under which your mortgage company
is allowing you to defer the mortgage
payment this long there were some that
were doing it through august
but you've done it all the way through
december now right
well we started a little late so we
started deferring them
in september okay and so you've deferred
september
october november and now december
right and when will those be repaid
um i think we're deciding to
start repaying them no what is that what
is the mortgage company requiring
i think it's three months so
i i think yeah three months so you have
to repay them within three months
i'm not sure actually
is there a chance you just stopped
paying your mortgage
maybe yeah so
the terms were because we were also
looking into refinancing
so i believe that what we had to do is
that we paid three consecutive months
and then we would have the option to
refinance so
okay um what do you owe on your home
uh 2 15.
what did your husband do that what kind
of job did he lose
he worked in i.t he works at it now why
is he not re-employed
uh he's been looking and it's just been
so difficult
um but in my team yeah
i know what does he do in i.t i teach
booming yeah i thought it jobs were like
a sign up sheet
yeah i think he needs to look a little
harder maybe
yes i think that's right
um i i i think we found the problem
the house payments are a symptom
so um how old are you guys
uh we're 30 years old and what has he
been doing
with his time bright tale
so he has been collecting unemployment
and
actively looking for a job and he
actually went back to school so
he's completing his degree in in i.t and
what he's doing
okay um you guys cannot afford for him
to do that
because you're not paying your house
payment and so if he can go back to
school while he's working full-time i'm
okay with that i'm not okay with him
collecting unemployment going to school
and piling up house payments because
you're going to lose your home
because you don't have any idea what you
signed up for that's what you told me
because you can't tell me what you
signed up for and so i don't know what
you've signed up for
but a lot of these deferred payments are
going to come due instantly and they're
going to want the whole thing
or they're going to want you to pay it
back in a very short period of time and
if you don't have a detailed plan
in writing for the mortgage company that
you understand which
apparently you don't um you have set
yourself up to lose the house if you
don't start paying double mortgage
payments and get current on your
mortgage and stay current
which involves him getting a job and so
that's what needs to happen you guys
need to have a january one new year's
resolution
to begin paying double house payments
because by then he is by god employed
hang on i'm gonna have kelly give you a
copy of ken coleman's book
um with a proximity principle i also
want your husband
today to go to kencoleman.com
and download every resource he's got
there on how to look for a job how to
interview
how to get your foot in the door because
i.t jobs are a booming this is freaking
miami florida
there is work to be done there in i.t
this is not you're not you don't live in
podunkville
there's lots of i.t jobs in miami
florida and today
call your mortgage company and find out
what kind of mess you're
going on you can't just walk out and
declare like michael scott walked out
and declared bankruptcy in the office
you can't just declare
i'm going to defer my mortgage payments
you've got to have dave said you've got
to have a written plan
everybody's on the same page you can't
just not send them a check
yeah and then they some woman told you
on the phone in customer service
who's had a job there for three days
that you can pay three payments and then
get refinanced
that's just that's the way you lose a
house is not having a deal done on this
and this is the danger of these
ridiculous coveted
um things that have come out
uh in the legislation and offerings from
the different companies under the name
of mercy
but they were really not merciful when
you get to looking at it
and that even includes unemployment uh
which is
uh kept him from going his and becoming
his best self
because i can promise you those it
workers have been landing jobs a lot
since he lost his
a lot um we've hired a buzz
i mean i don't know how many we've hired
uh probably 50 or 60 or 70 since march
in the i.t field alone
um so in the middle of covet
so it's uh um yeah that that's
you guys got to work on his career and
you need to get this detailed out on
your house before you lose it honey